لديك المزيد من التفاصيل حول المكان الذي
عثرت فيه الخدمة السرية على الكوكايين في
الجناح الغربي وكيف أن الدخل ، كما تعلم ،
يخضع لمعاينة
الخدمة السرية ، فهم يحققون حاليًا في
ما حدث خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ، لذا
يجب أن أحيلك إلى السر
أولاً ، الخدمة السرية في كل هذا ،
لكن هناك شيء واحد يمكنني مشاركته وهو أنني
سأشارك القليل أو أكثر من
المعلومات كما تعلمون أن
الرئيس والسيدة الأولى
وعائلتهم لم يتم الإبلاغ عنهم هنا
يوم الجمعة فقط
حيث لم يتم الإبلاغ عنهم في نهاية هذا الأسبوع.
منطقة كثيفة السفر حيث
يجب أن أكون أكثر
تحديدًا لزوار West Wing الذين يأتون
من خلال هذه المنطقة بالذات ،
ليس لدي أي شيء آخر لمشاركته
قيد التحقيق من قبل
الخدمة السرية وهذا في اختصاصهم